on vous a d'ailleurs posé la question
sur nos réseaux sociaux comment
faites-vous face à la hausse des prix du
carburant oui Aurélien et vous êtes 50%
à dire réduire vos déplacements 10% à
préférer les transports en commun et 10%
également à compenser en renonçant à
d'autres dépenses il n'y a pas que les
prix de l'essence qui augmente c'est une
inflation généralisée qui nuit notamment
aux étudiants une rentrée universitaire
coûterait à Tours cette année 2500 euros
en moyenne par étudiant selon l'agate
l'Association générale des associations
tourangelles étudiantes ces 92 euros de
plus qu'en 2022 alors comment
parviennent-ils tant bien que mal à
joindre les deux bouts Léa Turquie et
Lucas Chopin les ont rencontrés
Julie et Clémence font leur premier pas
à l'université cette année qui dit
rentrer du budget et là ça devient tout
de suite plus compliqué
c'est super cher et après j'ai économisé
en travaillant sinon mais après c'est
vrai que c'est un peu compliqué pour les
repas tout ça c'est mes parents qui me
donnent un peu d'argent enfin avec les
cours tout ça je me vois pas apprendre à
un travail à côté ça me ferait trop de
trucs et je pourrai pas je pense réussir
à avoir mon année tout ça
en février 2023 l'Insee indiquait une
augmentation des prix des produits
alimentaires de 14,8% sur un an les
étudiants font partie des plus touchés
par cette inflation alors il faut faire
des compromis il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de charges en plus qui viennent
s'ajouter notamment avec la hausse des
prix donc bah on voit ses achats à la
baisse et on se fait un peu moins
plaisir on fait attention à notre budget
on mange moins de trucs qu'on mange plus
on essaie de se faire des petits plats
maison pour que ça coûte moins cher
quand on va pas aller manger au kebab
tous les trois tous les trois quatre
jours quoi pour d'autres la solution se
trouve dans les bonnes affaires en
magasin pour renflouer les stocks sans
exploser le budget moi j'essaye de voir
les bonnes offres dans les magasins tout
ce qui est le bon de réduction etc
j'utilise aussi des applications comme
to good to go qui permettent de
récupérer des invendus dans les magasins
des dates courtes qui permettent du coup
d'économiser de l'argent cette année
l'Union nationale des étudiants de
France a fait le constat la vie
étudiante coûte près de 6,5% plus cher
qu'en 2022